une page de 30 ans entre Caroline et son
piano se tourne C habitante de Ben a
décidé de faire don de son instrument à
l'association unisson basée à trappe
elle ass sur le lien entre des
particuliers ou des entreprises
souhaitant se séparer de leur piano pour
les offrir à des lieux collectifs non
commerciaux un objet parfois chargé
d'histoire dont certains donateurs ont
du mal à se
séparer il va me manquer mais c'est
toujours mieux qu'il soit utilisé il va
être utilisé par des
jeunes dans une collectivité pas très
loin de chez nous donc c'est pour nous
c'était la la meilleure option plutôt
que de le garder ici
inutilisé arrivé dans son nouveau foyer
le 62e don d'unisson prend place dans le
hall du collège François rabelet à Ben
tous les élèves pourront jouer en libre
service au moment des récréation quel
que soit leur niveau le principal avait
remarqué les bienfaits de cet instrument
dans un autre établ issement
scolair ça apporte à la fois de la
gaieté de la sérénité et des temps de
calme parce que les élèves se regroupent
autour du piano et il y avait beaucoup
moins de dispersion des mouvements les
élèves étaient assez attentifs à leurs
camarades qui jou du piano et restait
autour
d'eux rien que dans le collège je suis
sûr qu'il y a plein de pianistes que je
connais pas et que je pourrais peut-être
discuter avec eux si je les vois jouer
et tout on pourrait échanger not savoir
et puis euh pourquoi pas jouer ensemble
allez merci un amour du piano pour
Sébastien peronau l'histoire commence en
2019 avec une amie il fonde unisson avec
la volonté de casser l'image élitiste de
cet objet pour l'ouvrir au plus grand
nombre la musique est qui est incarnée
par cet instrument qui est le piano est
justement un moyen de de se rassembler
de euh voilà il y a il peut y avoir à la
fois un petit côté poétique sur certains
morceaux mais aussi un un caractère
festif sur d'autres et c'est un peu
aussi la pluralité de cet instrument qui
qui fait sa force hôpitaux maisons de
retraite ou prison des lieux d'accueil
parfois atypiques pour recevoir les
précieux pianos de Sébastien une façon
de faire raisonner les notes pour rendre
plus chaleureux les couloirs de ces
[Musique]
lieux